everybody what's up we're back how's it
going
like we'll start over
California's on fire there's smoke
everywhere it's affected the audio of
our stream today very crazy it's
extremely hot outside we're surrounded
by fires happening yeah I think you guys
have been looking but there's flames
everywhere it's very scary and actually
a very serious situation a lot of people
been evacuated so I hope everybody out
there is being safe
don't be stupid if you see fire and
drive away from it yeah not towards it
yeah it may smell like a fun campfire
which is my maintenance this morning yes
like no it's not it's very dangerous I
hope everyone out there is being safe
and crazy yeah I shaved but I'm trying
to grow it back so that's what's
happening so hopefully it'll grow back
soon oh look at that beautiful lighting
there we go there we go I as you
couldn't hear before I wore my best ed
hardy shirt hit me with a full screen
would you hit me with a full screen
there Mouse look at that that's an
officially licensed and Hardy how much
money is that from a million yeah
million hey Lex Marlee I noticed you
like can you make that uh that other
chatlin right bigger so anyway we're
playing today we're playing this game
called persona 5 there it is right there
very exciting comes in a sleeve watch
this move that's right
and the reason why we're playing for
sona 5 is it's the old the game awards
are tomorrow night I believe at 5:30
Pacific time very exciting it'll be
streamed it's gonna be everywhere I'll
be attending which is super fun so if
you want to come along with me make sure
you're subscribed to our our you're
following our Instagram team cocoa
Instagram account because I'll be doing
about your Instagram stories I'll be
going with my friend Ryan Ridley who's a
writer and Raqqah Morty and we'll be
there and having a good time and this is
persona 5 is nominated for game of the
year
along with SuperMario Odyssey along with
a Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
along with player unknowns battlegrounds
and along with horizon zero dawn but
this one is the only one I haven't
played so I thought we'd played today
that shirt is amazing thank you shirt
will you wear tomorrow
what's your main word evolved tomorrow
I'm gonna wear I got a dress something
anything yeah I might be walking the red
carpet like I did last year so I'm it's
not gonna be a suit but I'll be wearing
probably something black like my heart
that's right Coffee kills hates
Instagram cool maybe you'll love it Rage
Against the Machine go but yeah you
should tune in anyway if you hate it so
gram to my stories cuz it'll be
fantastic we'll have a great time uh and
I hear there's gonna be amazing
after-party which you can all you all
come to me come with me to is that a
thing that people say okay anyway enough
hullabaloo let's play a little persona 5
I will tell Ryan Ridley then you missed
this podcast you could tell them
yourself if you follow along with our
stories that's right that's right that's
right that's right
[Music]
rising seven saw you burn yourself while
cooking that was hilarious
yeah I'm doing a cooking show every
Friday night on my own channel twitch.tv
slash Erin Blair tomorrow this Friday
I'll be cooking I were gonna do the last
of crust so I'm gonna be playing The
Last of Us while making a pizza and last
week we played Super Mario cada see
which was me cooking Italian cod and
playing Super Mario Odyssey and I burned
myself three times in six minutes
so it was red by the way uh probably the
following week I'm gonna be doing red
bread Redemption making some bread okay
so in this game apparently we play a
high school student spend the days as a
normal student go to school hang out
with friends hold a part-time job now I
hated high school it was one of the
worst times in my life and that's why I
ended up buying shirts like this to
cover my insecurities so I can't wait to
relive it through this game that's right
Lex Marley oh please share your channel
Beth we'll put a link in the in the chat
TV slash Aaron flirt but also yeah just
know that I'm not a good cook and please
don't try to cook what I'm cooking cuz
it's really bad the world's not should
it be as full of distortion and ruined
can no longer be avoided that's true
those who oppose fate and desire change
from time to time to refer to as
tricksters I'm not sure that that's what
a trickster mean you are the trickster
now is the time to rise against the
abyss of distortion alright so far this
game sounds insane the fluffernutter 365
the cookie streams are Fiasco yes
they're a fiasco I don't know how to
cook I'm sorry
Oh Perce Kona five or you make scones
oh oh that's a great pun that's a great
pun I'm we're gonna I'm gonna keep track
of all these we're gonna keep track of
all these horizon zero prawn and purse
gonna five oh I love it
Kevin says I'm new to these live streams
well welcome Kevin who is the woman on
the laptop and how long have I loved her
her name is Beth Moravsky now love is a
strong word I'd say more despises also a
strong word
I respect her I respect her yes I
respect her she does everything here she
makes she's the team work that makes the
dream work and she runs team koco.com
with an iron fist she smashes all those
who are in her way she's in human forest
fire and she loves hotels reading and
fine fine ones yes I actually hear you
enjoy terrible wines actually she enjoys
terrible water that's right what was the
book you just finished that you really
liked a little light little life I
highly recommend there you go
it's not like a cool new book it's gonna
be any best of list this year I don't
think it was from like 2015 I think it
is a cool book it's not a new book but I
hear it's a really cool book yes alright
so far we're in what looks like lax
mystery transference uh sex that I
wasn't paying attention and I feel like
this
game is story and I've already messed it
up I love the look of this game dude
look at this this is beautiful
wow this game is awesome she also led
the since the citizen corgis Marauder
you're correct
Aaron Davis says mmm shitty wine exactly
I need to turn this up a bit
hey Mouse can you make that right one a
little bigger - oh this is a I love the
music in this game now why is there
water everywhere agent or is it a jet
who knows I just okay where do I run
[Music]
okay this is a great game
I wish they'd port this to the PC p5 is
styling charisma for days who can't wait
zacchara's Kevin well thanks for joining
us persona yes M fun wait am ia Joker am
i I'm the trickster is that the same as
the Joker Wow oh my god wow he turns
into a demon whoa holy crap dude this
game is insane oh my god I love this all
I have is a dagger uh-oh
gun take aim guard defend yourself
attack minitex
oh baby this is great well that's my new
catchphrase is ooh baby I'm just warning
everybody
this knife is doing the trick Oh weird
tentacle Anubis is kind of pissed at me
oh I see okay so it's kind of a
role-playing game fire gun I don't want
to use all my ammo that's a bad idea
right was a sacrificial pyre pyre Keeper
let's just kill him all right boom
pull out before the bouquet well
PlayStation now have you a good PC you
could try streaming it when it gets on
there fair enough use your persona what
does that mean
could you defeated them with ease more
of them be careful Oh shade the music is
just going on the whole time dude I love
this go
what door alright let's go let's go why
would I run does it look like I'm
running through acid puddles oh yeah
baby copy kill said say I can't say that
on this stream but thank you should I be
looking around in here I'm just escaping
I guess a lot of posters back here
[Music]
still loads them alright Oh put your
dukes over here oh there another door
back over here oh here we go
oh this is the way I came cool oh you
used triangle with some in your persona
Oh got it okay
we're in a dream world this does seem
rather dreamy this feels very matrix s
masers s I like that starting like this
and now with a slow tutorial I agree
Marian wears Conan Conan hey Brazil
what's up Diego
Conan's up in his office currently on a
writers meeting hide in everybody away
if you just keep fighting hiding the
shadows and sneak past we've seen
opening got it got it okay this keeps
love's a restriction on streaming it
past a certain point I don't think so
seeing as it's out and it's been out for
a while
and I bought it pre-owned so I feel like
it shouldn't oh wait unless you mean it
gets gross or whatever we'll see oh I
heard a block seen maybe Oh
[Music]
that's crazy all right you want to go
fullscreen there Molly
I guess so we're not supposed to stream
this porno it says we're asking players
to refrain from street mere posting
video past the end of the in-game date
of 1119 so did you that's like live day
by day but not to go past oh I see okay
like point in the game I see okay but
this is like the beginning of the
tutorial I feel like we're probably fine
already can go back to the game
we've limit each to be at most 90
minutes and we're only gonna do 60 and
they never enforced the rules on yeah
okay fair enough fair enough all right I
see they don't want people they don't
want to be ruined because it's probably
a lot of spoilers see yeah I guess you
wouldn't want people extreme like Fight
Club yeah you know past a certain point
got it okay a lot of big twitch so let's
see definitely saying a lot of big
twitch streamers and youtubers have done
entire plays fair enough we're only
playing for an hour so we're not gonna
get that far hundred hours good lord
watch hogs - that's funny
you make big great bacon or something
digging this music it's very My Chemical
Romance restrained with Gerard Way back
in the day
this game has twists that make Fight
Club look like the most straightforward
thing ever really dude Oh bill ass says
we're still a considerable distance away
from the cutoff time maybe I should play
this game this would be fun although
it's gonna be hard I'm not gonna get far
at all says monster was although to be
fair I guess if they don't want us to
stream past a certain point I don't want
to ruin you know the developers this
game made an awesome game I don't want
to ruin their whole thing watchdogs I
just make hot dogs one my speed good
call you know we used to have in the
office which was great back in the day
late night we had one of those hot dog
makers that's like a toaster but it's
got a little hold now this is gonna get
gross but a little hole that you put the
hot dog in
why did I even bring this up and then
you put like and then the buns you also
put in and then it pops up and it makes
the hot dog I don't know why I brought
that up that was just asking the chat to
be gross metal beer solid
not sure you know what I did try
actually know what I did try to make my
own beer once I don't know if I've ever
told this story publicly yeah and so
when I turned 21 my sister got me a beer
making kit and I was in college and I
was like nah I didn't I was like you
know what I'm gonna make a beer because
I'm obviously modest and not a complete
arrogant ass I was like I'm gonna make a
beer that's never been made before my
first time I'm gonna make a rhubarb beer
I like strawberry rhubarb sounds good oh
there's strawberry beer yeah exactly I
like story word pie right exactly
rhubarb right but what I didn't know and
what I didn't bother to find out because
again I'm an arrogant ass is I wasn't of
course not
I didn't realize that beer to make beer
it's like a hole it's a very tightly
controlled process including like
everything has to be a clean and B it's
all about like bacteria and fermenting
in a certain way and stuff so I was just
like oh to make rhubarb beer I'm sure I
just put rhubarb in it that's a terrible
idea
don't do that so I went out and bought a
bunch of rhubarb I put it like stuffed
it in the thing let it ferment I'm
shocked I'm still a lot mother and if
you watch the Super Mario cotta see
stream last week you should be shocked
to that I'm still alive after it cook
under cooking that fish but so I tried
to make rhubarb beer so oh I think we go
we're only playing an hour right let's
do it
so you wait like an you wait like a
month or something or twenty days or
something for it to ferment so you know
and you know my roommates in college are
all like oh rhubarb beer it can't wait
to taste it we're all bunch of drugs I
busted open
we stood I immediately spit it out
because it tastes exactly like honey
baked ham
exactly like if you ground-up honey
baked ham and made it into a liquid and
then put a bunch of weird particles
floating in it that's what the beer
tastes like my rhubarb beer uh and the
crazy thing is you could the way the kit
worked you only could make four giant
things of it so I had four huge things
of rhubarb beer are a honey baked ham
beer basically disgusting ham beer and
it was gross but then you know what like
a week later when we had drank all the
alcohol in our house we ended up
drinking it when one of my roommates
ended up drinking it and then riding his
bike naked down the street I don't know
it's a whole big thing all right
but yeah kids so don't try to make you
know don't try to fly too close to the
Sun when it comes to making beer light
just go go with a very pedestrian you
know because I could have made a
delicious beer but instead I tried to
fly too close to the Sun okay let's see
here
do I have to put in a last name can we
be done and then I'm gonna kind of do
what Prince did you know like bleh bleh
bleh yeah let's be bleh bleh bleh what
are they gonna come out with a game
where it's like they say your name you
know oh you know what I'm gonna do no
you know what I'm gonna do no this is
what we're gonna do this is what we do
we're gonna do kids we're gonna do in
light of my in light of my story yeah
we're gonna do this is why I should
never have kids or be allowed or be
allowed to have a child hand beer that
is my name it's right hand beer guys
that's what it is
uh yeah Madeline soon as we all drank it
I mean mostly my roommate Tom and it was
a mess I'll fall out for did if you had
a name on their list
oh really out of Lovelace that's cool
excuse me ham beer this name is hot NBA
2k says your name oh that's pretty cool
I'm glad we're finally getting into that
what is it like welcome to the game
I'm Bear you know it is it like in a
robot voice do they actually you know
what I love in games talking and people
on their cell phones oh hey thanks Kirby
son nine eight seven I got it from
screen comm slash dumb stuff it's a
legit ed hardy shirt at least that's
what they told me when I bought it the
term is you a bad decision stole my beer
but I'm growing it back so I'm gonna
look like crap for the next leg well for
the rest of my life because that's just
what I look like but my face will not
have a beard on it for the next couple
weeks
beer is sacred yeah
Petri this is back in college this is
when I was 21 I haven't drank beer in
the last like three years or four years
they just call you you please name your
first child ham beer I'm gonna name all
my kids ham beer but with a different
amount of MS so like my firstborn will
be hand beer my second will be ham beer
my third will be ham beer I shouldn't
have children
Skylar Sampson you can go to scream calm
slash dumb stuff but screened with a k'
I think is where I got this shirt and a
bunch of my other shirt dizzi death
clearly you've never seen me stream
before I don't have confidence
jogo ham beers good used in court
George Foreman did name all of his kids
George but he's famous so they're gonna
have the name George Foreman and George
Foreman jr. Jordan Georgia Foreman or
Georgina how is it even possible all
right so this is setting up the thing I
think you could steal other people's
hearts and look into their hearts and do
things with their hearts
I think that's Purse gonna five I love
that yeah now on me era albino ham beer
is gonna be my sixth kid now I'm
hallucinating because this is what
happened by the way when I drank the
hand beer I started seeing crazy things
the term you see Aaron sucks the girls
way too many kids named him beer you
could do it man have lots of children
choke Nader I feel yet this is the Hamm
beer fairy talking dosage
slay away camp is better I don't know
Shawn you know what I really like the
Friday the 13th game is pretty dope yeah
we played I played dead dead by daylight
I didn't like it as much as Friday 13th
cuz it's not it's not as like it's not
as a well-put-together game Hamm beer
fairy baby there we go
does Conan pay me and pesos and hotdogs
he doesn't pay me actually I got fired
like four years ago so I just work here
for this is I volunteer I actually work
at the library Harley Quinn weird you're
my spirit animal so weird I love that
this game is basically playing like a
cartoon it's awesome hammock in Pig Blue
Ribbon got nothing dead by daylight was
odd for sure
fish Friday the 13th oh I don't know
waffle tarts stir Friday the 13th is a
better one I've said this before but out
what is happening here I've said this
before about our commissary does the
most annoying thing in the world
alright they do walk Friday yeah now
look it's either walk Wednesday or stir
Friday
you can't have walk Friday's what are
you doing what are you doing you make me
crazy
and then I think they also had Taco
Mondays I'm not making this up I'm
almost positive they're talking one this
O'Malley didn't they have Taco Mondays
for a while a long time ago that cotton
they're trying to make me crazy do you
understand they're trying to drive me
insane
ham beard the librarian
a good point we've seen we've seen how
you've cooked fish already yeah cook not
Taco Tuesdays to blings
it was Taco Monday's that make me insane
but I will say every Thursday they do
have like Thanksgiving oh yeah they have
like turkey stuffing gravy cranberry
sauce so yeah do you want to gain a lot
of weight come to the warner brothers
just bulk up every Thursday just go
straight in for Thanksgiving oh dude
this is like John wick to what's
happening right now by the way I heard
they started production John wick 3 very
excited I love that man John wick was so
fun John wick too is great
[Music]
revenge of the Hamm beer this game is
awesome Psycho Mantis what I ever tie my
hair neon-green says Rick Rice Reese
both on Conan dyed my hair orange and
brown on late night back in the day it's
on YouTube actually yeah it's somewhere
when I first started working there and
then he shaved this part and put a stamp
there put it seen the back of my head
shave one of my eyebrows it's one of my
first times I'm like you know what
people do for fame
julik says I love the John wick series I
agree that would be might dream
Thanksgiving it's the best this is cool
man come on you're going to the library
to check out a cookbook junior that's
right just make sure you follow the
cookbook we need to get you a shirt or
hat from the hand beer brewing company I
should do that actually sir bunch of
people are talking I always take the
stairs guys back streets let's do it
this is cool I like this game I'm gonna
be honest I thought I would hate this
game I thought I would I hated the evil
within I wasn't a fan haven't played
evil within two cuz sometimes games get
too weird but this game feels like it's
so well done and it has a good sense of
humor about itself
and I really like it yeah watch Conan
die my hair hey O'Malley go go
fullscreen did you this is what we're
talking about by the way this is the
that's me yeah that's amazing yeah
that's it that's the end of that's the
end of the that's the end if you want to
watch that that's the end of it it's
amazing
it's terrible absolutely terrible I by
the way from that at the end of that
remote at the end of that remote if you
watch it I bust out of a picture of my
own face I have one of those photos on
my wall so in my apartment which is
maybe why I'm single
I have a 9 foot tall picture of my own
face and each eye is like this big and
it kind of follows you around oh yeah
everybody's freaking yeah what I told
you guys I don't joke about that man
my life is weird enough that I don't
have to make things up unfortunately how
many inspirations is out of preset I
look like a Backstreet Boys job
extra-thick time lizard that's right I
was obese you're right Shane lost 90
pounds you can watch my short film how
to lose weight in four easy steps
by the way Conan's in it there you go
and it'll also tell you how to lose
weight I wouldn't recommend it though
so what are we supposed to be doing here
we're just kind of checking stuff out I
guess we can go into shops this is cool
oh I'm not going in because I'm ahead to
my new lodging okay now you know I hate
when games are unclear go dude says
you're see you see heroes sakura's
residence where is that I'm aged well I
don't know Jarvis things won't get
better that's what let's talk to the old
man okay
has nothing to say to me best advice
yeah don't eat bread you don't need it
coffee shop I should go to the coffee
shop okay
where's the coffee shop right here okay
I examined it this parts pretty unclear
you have to talk to the right people
okay cool all right so we got to talk to
people so let's talk secondhand shop can
I go in here No okay let's talk to this
guy unfriendly officer jeez oh oh here
we go one ask for directions
yes take a right after what do you say
take a right after the stairs oh you
know what maybe it's uh it's this way
here oh here we go
wait saligan someone's had to go to the
burger shop and take the burger
challenge the burger challenge okay
where's that at
Berger somewhere here's the calculator
store not thirsty right now no there's a
secondhand shop do the burger challenge
it's hilarious yeah the shadow pants so
this is the reason why we're playing
this is this is a game of the Year
nominee for the Game Awards tomorrow
night which is that either 5:30 or 6:00
Pacific time I believe I'm gonna be
going so make sure you follow team Coco
on Instagram and I will be oh I think
it's over here and yeah you could come
along with me to the game or it'll be
really fun okay it's the station just
past here I need to head to heroes house
there's a creepy dark alleyway yeah so
follow us and you'll be doing a lot of
Instagram stories from the game words
tomorrow it'll be great
and so this is one of persona 5 is one
of the game of the Year nominees the
other ones are super Mario Odyssey
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild which
is obviously incredible as is Super
Mario to see horizon zero dawn and
player unknown battlegrounds which is
fun I'm hoping I'm waiting for that to
port to xbox so I can play player in
novellas I'm not a huge PC gamer really
want to play this is on switch I'm not
sure what's near automata
I gotta check that out
[Music]
so I need to go back to the station what
am i doing Oh found him
here we go fine it sorry sir Cedric
Connick oh man Jesus you want to play it
at the cafe okay I thought we just were
at the cafe damn it where's the cafe at
it's this way
there we go
I'll go inside all right we did it yeah
it is coming you know what Teemo [ __ ]
- uh it kind of I don't like exclusivity
in games for consoles I I mean it
doesn't make any sense to me it's kind
of like you have to have a special DVD
player to watch a certain movie right
why like you know what demons everywhere
yeah that's the one Jonathan 520 Thank
You vertical is the name of a shellfish
used for farming pearls what is going on
is are we smokin eat read they did say
that was today that's exactly what
somebody says right before a car crashes
in somewhere well we're totally fine
destroy oh cool I'm glad by Sookie
Oh what now there's been a string of
those rampage accident I think it is
your concern manager you're just asking
for a rampage accident to happen
four hours for just a single lecture
esteem prima is there I missed that
whole thing where I was just a cup of
joe play your cards right and bang the
teacher so your ham
that's right hand beer here please take
care of me
my name is ham beer look at my awesome
pants I have what's heard oh I'm so
Jewish I doubt you'll be in my custody
over the next year got it
I'm not unruly dude I'm a nice dude NIR
is an awesome game just try it Justin
what's it for what's near for your
autumn autumn
otama how do you say Tom Manama of
course he made a teacher well that's
tricky he's like well here's a bunch of
garbage mother wouldn't you say like if
you're taking care of a kid would you
like this is what we're doing
like give the kid his own here's a
garage on he didn't even stand
this guy's a dick no a PC and ps4 all
right best pants ever I know the
teachers a man oh it's like a Tommy Tom
with odds atomic Tom I don't know how
this shirt I can't see anything over the
brightness of this shirt yeah kicked his
ass okay don't be a dick I do love a
good expositional scene yeah okay yeah
I'm not the one talking about anything
necessary
a whole year oh boy hey man you know
what you're the one who's showing off
his ankles all right okay got it yep I
got it
understood you Jin tomorrow okay stop
asking him questions let's just go here
yeah the school you be attending oh my
god
you know there's a thing in show
business which is just like show don't
tell
just let's just go there why are you
telling me all this I don't need thanks
there had to be a better way to get that
information across to us you know take
your time it says I'll be living here
starting today I should check out what's
in here oh boy okay all right you know
what dream daddy was a way better gaming
this so far this is like that Tom Petty
more music video all right let's see yep
no one can use it while it's like this
too bad I'm not strong enough to lift a
a frickin plastic tarp covered in dust
okay I should start cleaning it oh man
this hand I knew there was something
interesting about this game we started
it started it started - great it started
- great yeah there we go
I knew this Kenson 9 under says my first
playthru this was a hundred and two
hours Jesus Christ
[Music]
I got a check outs layaway camp I'll
check it out I'll check it out I really
loved if there's anything like Friday
the 13th I'll love it so it's really fun
all right up captain jerkface is back
haenam just went ham on cleaning heavy
story dude if you don't like reading
leave okay fair enough but this is the
beginning to be fair yeah we ever really
missed much I mean I get it I understand
like we have to go this guy's gonna take
care of us like I understand that's the
whole thing I understand this game is
you know but whatever it needs to be a
game where you just clean I don't need
to be playing a game like that I need to
do that for my apartment for real
I don't even clean at home ain't gonna
do it on a game meaty legs I'm gonna go
back for nothing all right I'm gonna
clean up close up shop and get outta
here myself
bye oh my god this guy why does this guy
my my guardian how did he moves us
forward one day can I just go to sleep
forever okay time is limited don't I
know it
well I'm gonna game so why should I
sleep I guess I have to though right
that's the whole point of this he's
telling me I should sleep so I sleep
changing go to sleep fine
Oh a lot of the game dialogue is
character based rather than story based
that's cool I ain't here to read I here
to play video games persona games you're
playing the life of a Japan I'm a high
school student along with all the boring
stuff like making friends and mundane
tasks arrest trial criminal record oh no
this is me by the way laying in bed
every night I just think about all the
terrible things I've done and crickets I
have a terrible cricket problem in my
apartment a lot of crickets I'd almost
rather have roaches because roaches are
quiet oh you know what I'm saying
bugs are bugs crickets are like yeah so
far right now feces doesn't spread
disease don't they they probably spread
spread disease just as bad
question from the chat is it grosser to
have crickets roaches or hands cuz I
also have ants in my bathroom
roaches I don't like things that oh wait
let's go solve it
oh wait how do we help this person
yeah let's go save them let's do let's
don't you
oh dude let's put the hurt on him yeah
let's get I have to save her get up
there dude my god this guy's a dick you
don't need the police it's me and my
over the shoulder bag I'm gonna stop you
come on dude get in there I'm just what
am i doing a standing here come on man
elbow to the back of the head this
douche with this glasses nighttime yeah
what it did eat those glasses get in the
car what no border that oh that's what
happened oh I see okay fair enough
I hope I killed that guy is screw him Oh
pee pee pee
I [ __ ] up one time I leave him I left
over in and out my old apartment only to
take up a stream of ants coming from
outside one time I found a piece of I
was cleaning my room this is when I was
much younger and found a piece of apple
pie under my bed and it was black oh my
god yeah that's pretty great I thought I
deleted it WTF if you have crickets you
know over there are pitbull flashback
alright well let's go to sleep my skin
looks great clear my skin is see if my
face look like that without a beard I
would go beardless with us in my life I
just have what's this call to fill broom
I got a real long fill broom guys this
is too long yeah this then it's too long
so I got a guy gotta cover it up why was
pine under my bed I don't know Mary I
just put it there because I was eating
it I think I was on the floor
oh no no I'm in jail I feel like I'm an
emotional Jail normally
I'm going to the first dungeon what does
that mean how am other dungeons I'm not
gonna skip now let's keep it going I
could you know what I don't I look like
a Chicago cop if I have a mustache it's
not a good look for me some guys can
pull it off I can't who doesn't have a
PI into their bed emergency party thank
you scheme Eric yeah exactly
alright shades of the shining here very
creepy
I also found a banana one time that was
black and like flat under my bed I
usually clean I think the moral of story
is I need to clean out under my bed more
often yeah handle bars play I don't know
man it just it doesn't look good trust
me what does this like this doesn't look
good
what's going on here do you need some
gum to my go this guys need some Visine
it's very Oswald Cobblepot best way to
eat is on the floor of course Rob's
gaming channel I like the characters in
this game now I got these Mickey kids on
my ass Jesus you got unfriendly police
officers you got my guardian who's a
real like pieces crime goes whoop
piece of human crap and then you got
these kids were just super [ __ ] kids
but master of this place Igor that guy's
boogers must be insane do you think what
he picks his nose he gets buggers that
are like pickle sized important matters
should i I love when they're like music
I can I can just ask a question that has
no bearing on anything just keep talking
you know it's like they just want to
know if you're there so you can't just
spaghetti buggers for sure this guy
there is no so zeroes actually super
cool yeah we'll see can guys intense
dreams you know what this is this is
every time I've ever taken nyquil this
pain to just be called nyquil five this
is exactly what happens when I take
nightlife think like I'm in third grade
and vampires are attacking the house
it's like crazy your most tickle sized
buggers man rehabilitated for now its
height that is your only means to avoid
do you have the result to challenge the
distortion of the world no man I'm
there's a lot of there's a lot of stink
it's just like stink or Axe body spray
what is this there's something wrong
with these dudes air conditioning this
can't be good man also clearly dude we
all know you're going bald just shave it
off like growing it long in the back
it's not good it doesn't it's not
helping I ain't got go oh you sat in my
seat great can I get a collaborator two
eyes is that possible I got two
collaborators neither one is dentin
perception maybe I can just like duct
tape their heads together their heads
together and then if they would be like
one yeah slowly I think is the only
women understand anything if you keep
talking here chopper combats only a day
away ooh now you're talking about I'm
speaking my language
it's the ether hummingbird person there
we go
yeah after Franken Sanket Wow Elizabeth
Theatre and Margaret that's cool wait
who is Margaret in Frankenstein
all right now boring back to yo cool
this is euro got a cool Fedora oh she's
getting the letters as if this guy
couldn't be more of it dick hey O'Malley
can you move the thing so we could see
the dudes face just to the top left our
top rights fine top rights fine look at
this dude he could be more of a dick now
he's got a fedora perfect Henchy so
Giro's know where his best outfit ah
also look at this guy's posture come on
man stand up straight we got great okay
I do like this guy's jacket shirt combo
it's a pretty dope this game is very
time-consuming well we'll see about that
John Bruce what if I skip everything
Sunday the day there's no school in
Japan were going to the in school oh my
god dude we get it but it doesn't matter
how young you dress we all know you're
not young chopper to reiterate just so
we're clear you will immediately be
expelled if you cause any problems this
guy's this guy is like me when I got my
hair cut yeah I know everyone's a dick
to me Lex Luthor is my principal here's
your 12 year old teacher hi
sit I said I Oh I'm super smart I'm 10
years old my mom can drive my mom drives
me to school every day
Jubilees very soon hopefully this is the
kingpin from spider-man exactly and if
by chance you cause any problems
yeah I know no one so far can protect me
everybody hates me
this douche is wearing a fedora this guy
needs to cut back on the old complex
carbs how insecure is the principal that
he has to have a nameplate on assist it
says principal oh look they're having a
dick off who could be a bigger dick okay
I get it my god guys please come to the
faculty office when you arrive at school
cuz that's what happens to new kids
they're like come to the office I'll
show they're just like go to class
you haven't seen anything yet some of
the stuff you deal with in this game
it's rated M for a reason Oh
oh cool now he's at least now he's not
talking anymore thank God yeah I think
I'll scrape by you know it's it's time
I'm I'm a dick back to these guys also
I'm wearing a wig retired school never
changes well I'm so glad we took this
drive to the school on a Sunday oh yeah
yeah Jersey wearing teacher don't talk
to her she's 12 years old have a little
confidence for the school and he's not
wearing a jersey by the way is he okay
oh I hate when guys are like this yeah I
work out hey which way which way to the
gym this way or this way you know like
yeah I know
apparently everybody just wants to kick
me out of school why are they even
letting me in this school
Jesus this is these are terrible
teachers two teachers want to educate
kids persona six kill all transfer
students exactly oh cool
more exposition yeah isn't there that
tournament coming up that we need to
tell the player about somehow so we're
gonna do it in a weird conversation all
right bye this is a totally normal
conversation between two totally normal
teachers who are excited about their
youth
Oh God gotta grow my left tricep oh I
put this guy's terrible body odor
doesn't it look like somebody would just
like doesn't shower Oh a greasy hair it
seems fun also your jerk everyone is a
dick in this game still rated M for
messy I did see we didn't tear
somebody's head off I think and some guy
like split in half and a tentacle face
came out of him so I was pretty cool
yeah exactly got any bandages because
check these cuts hey do you know which
way it will you know how far away is it
veterinarian cuz these puppies are sick
yeah okay goes on and on I don't I just
don't get it like what so the thing is
like are we supposed to win these people
over I happen to agree to do it demons
at work cutting the timetable state
radio apparently is a very long game
with a large story so they need to set
we've a large tapestry in the beginning
interesting stuff begins I'm 411
well our streams almost done so I feel
like we're not gonna make it there I'll
have to steal their hearts I get it oh
dang this is like speed too didn't speed
to happen on a train or maybe that was a
boat speed to happen on a boat cruise
control time and space sent in a fan oh
this dude is crazy don't spoil the game
you dicks guys stand behind the yellow
line you're making me nervous
pretty sure that's not I think is really
cool I don't think she's listening to
you dude when somebody talks to me and
I'm just like this I think that's an
international sign for you stop talking
to me yeah that's why you stay behind
the yellow line exactly it's obviously
demons inside of people everything's
linked that's what you're thinking
correct yeah
she's probably thinking I wish this old
dude would stop talking to me you and I
haven't gone for a drink in a while all
right I must be going
again I love the animation in this game
is so cool this game is a beautifully
looking game beautiful looking game is
oh that is that my interrogator no
that's not my god that's not weird nose
dude this is him never trust anyone
wearing black gloves I'm gonna say that
right now they're always a murderer or a
thief everybody wants to bang this woman
this game just like is it like bangable
x' or something she's banging all the
time all right well we're back in the
cafe pretty exciting
give me a Bethany con for drinking a
while or ever but we drink in the office
all the time we drink in the office
constantly I'm drinking got some water
right now I do drink an unhealthy amount
of seltzer in the office it gives us
such thing it's like too many bubbles
yeah but isn't it bad fruity pretty bad
alright well so zero dudes a drip pretty
big drip yep well something exciting
better happen in the next three minutes
because that's how long we're streaming
for so
yep water that's right aka come on it's
not vodka it's tequila that's my liquor
hashtag ham fam okay yeah okay bye
heard the exciting stuff happens on
April 11th see you later
time and space I don't know when you're
gonna get a response for your fan
correction it depends how good it was if
we respond or not so hopefully it's a
good fan correction do I press the
options button okay I guess I should
rest up yeah I'm gonna save this you
know what maybe I'll play this game on
my own thing on Sunday
fawful yeah I know it's not a faster but
I wanted to play it cuz it's a game of
your nominee I will say I'm sure it gets
good but more like yeah exactly it's
kind of like takes a little while to get
going now I got to go downstairs okay
can I go somewhere all right leave junk
littered floor table storage
[Music]
how do I get downstairs man kind of get
that phone I know I'll examine the junk
litter floor how do I get out of here
I'm on a window
it's our door somewhere oh here we go oh
great perfect yes it gets going big-time
all right I I enjoy reading I'm just
saying I just don't enjoy boredom but
again I think this game is great
I'm sure it's it's a game of the year
for a reason who is this what all right
you know flip the sign got it
just leave me alone okay fine yeah okay
bye see ya okay got it
change the sign now they're better when
I change just sign something amazing
better happy because this we're ending
the stream here in a second wait did I
just leave by accident oh why am i
outside oh there we go change the sign
why would I do that
okay good go back now there's gonna be a
crazy dream shootout right all right
let's go to sleep and then we're gonna
end this dream
the beginning of persona 3 was to three
hours of exposition fair enough
that's what makes no there's nothing
else go to sleep I mean I wait to sleep
in those pants obviously they look
pretty restrictive hey you take the
train to school this is exactly me by
the way I'm going to sleep I love like
my favorite thing is like all right I
got to get off the internet and go to
sleep then I go to bed and I get on then
I'm like I wonder what's on the smaller
Internet I just look at the exact same
thing just smaller
oh that weird app it keeps showing up
god damn mall where no dream tonight
Beth why is sims 4 so addicted look at
this look at this whoa Monday it is ok
oh no dreams all right well I think
that's it for the stream a 30 percent a
5 I gave you gave you a shot everybody
said something exciting happens or 11 I
didn't see it but maybe I'll try playing
this on on Sunday on my own channel so I
guess tune into that maybe not we'll see
guys thank you much so much for joining
us once again please follow team cook on
Instagram and snapchat to follow along
as I go to the game Awards tomorrow
night that's 5:30 Pacific time it'll be
streamed and good luck to persona 5 good
luck sister Maria Odyssey good luck to
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
player unknown battle grant player
knowns battlegrounds and horizon zero
dawn hope one of you one of you will win
game of the year can't wait to see who
it's gonna be
make sure you tune in Friday night
twitch that TV slash air and blare to
watch me try to cook we're gonna be
doing the last of crust playing The Last
of Us and cooking a pizza and you can
probably hear the crickets that are in
my kitchen apologies in advance I will
probably burn myself thank you all for
joining us we'll see you guys later see
you later bye
you